When should I consider doing another cheek swab?
So I'm often said that
well, first of all, when you start with me, I always think it's good within
30 to 90 days to do another cheek swab just to recheck things and make things work things who are going in the right direction
but it partly depends on
the person. So if the person starts with us
Which isn't been very many people lately that are like real stable. So
most people that have started the last six months are more advanced and
Then I do suggest usually when we do the initial cheek swab that we do a check with least within 60 days
To do another recheck if the person is stable and you're doing really well
But I don't know that you need to do what other cheek swab until differently. So something's changed
So I often have said that you use the cheek swab test like you'd like to feel like you need to go to the doctor like something is up something has changed
If you're monitoring with blood tests if you're monitoring with scans or however you're monitoring your cancer and
things feel stable or you feel like you're improving that I don't know that you need to do another cheek swab
But if you're if you feel like you're not going in the right direction then by all means that's what you should
So even if it's the last time to that I just did a cheek swab 30 days ago, but I feel like I'm
Prashing and going downhill then there's nothing wrong with doing another one now. So all depends on that person's symptoms